après l'échec de luxembourg la france
répercute par les augmentations des prix
agricoles sociale cgt cfdt scène tente
d'organiser un 1er mai unitaire
demain beatrix sera reine des pays-bas à
la cérémonie en direct sur antenne
madame monsieur bonsoir
seul contre tous madame thatcher premier
ministre britannique a refusé toutes les
perches de compromis que lui tendait ses
partenaires européens au sommet de
luxembourg résultats échec sur le
problème de la fixation des prix
agricoles et la contribution de lèse au
budget de la communauté conclusions
l'europe apparaît comme paralysés mais
cet échec ne doit pas masquer les
réussites de la coopération européenne
exemple aujourd'hui même la france et
l'allemagne viennent de signer un accord
pour lancer en commun deux satellites de
télévision directe philippe dumais voici
donc la maquette du futur satellite de
télévision directe
il s'appellera tf1 et sera construit
sous la responsabilité de l'aérospatiale
l'autre satellite construit par les
allemands ctv ça l'accord franco
allemand prévoit une mise en commun des
connaissances et des études pour limiter
les coûts de production les deux
satellites seront lancés début 84 par
deux fusées ariane
le premier avantage de ce système est
une couverture parfaite du territoire
souhaité pour l'instant la couverture de
chacun des deux pays ne déborde pas trop
sur l'autre mais on envisage de lancer
des satellites qui pourront eux couvrir
toute l'europe
offrant ainsi un choix plus grand
téléspectateurs pour leur programme
l'allemagne et la france envisage aussi
de vendre ce satellite à d'autres pays
parce que ce sera rentable mais
finalement pour vous cela ne changera
pas grand chose
il ya d'abord sur votre toit à l'antenne
aura une forme différente
une sorte de bol comme celui-ci
peut-être plus petits coûtant
aujourd'hui encore assez cher et dans
l'intérieur de votre maison
rien le poste sera le même on lui
adjoindra au départ un petit meuble de
ce genre là qui permettra la conversion
directe du signal reçu par l'antenne
vers votre téléviseur
le satellite de télévision directe
français possède trois canaux deux
seulement pour l'instant seront utilisés
pour la première et pour la 2ème chaîne
la troisième canal sera attribué
ultérieurement
après 84 peut-être à une chaîne privée
mais en fonction des besoins
le rôle de notre troisième chaîne reste
en régionale les surnoms donnés aux
hommes et aux femmes politiques sont
rarement usurpé ainsi madame thatcher
donc que tous les journalistes appellent
la dame de fer n'a pas plié devant ses
partenaires une position intransigeante
qui éloigne encore un peu plus les côtes
anglaises du continent mais qui est
généralement bien accueillis en grande
bretagne londres
gérard subban margaret thatcher avait
que des gones boxe
merveilleuse magee elle fait tout sauter
pour 1 milliard échec du sommet les
français sont furieux ce sont les grands
titres de la presse britannique qui
refait bien l'opinion de l'homme de la
rue allons les anglais sont en effet
admiratif devant madame thatcher qui a
tenu tête ainsi fermement à l'ensemble
des pays européens l'ont met l'accent
beaucoup sur sa personnalité
notamment sur l'interview qu'elle a
accordée à un magazine féminin où elle
affirmé c'est vrai je suis parfois très
mal coiffée mont rouge à lèvres et mal
me mais je suis efficace
après cet échec du sommet de luxembourg
se font dans les anglais sont inquiet
car ils ne savent pas ce qu'il va
advenir du marché comme art il semble
bien qu'il ya quelque chose de cassé
mais ils ne veulent pas rond il espère
que dans les prochaines semaines
peut-être qu'une solution sera trouvée
grâce à la prochaine réunion des
ministres des finances
en effet même s'ils ne sont pas toujours
satisfait les britanniques savent ce que
le marché commun leur apporter notamment
une augmentation de leurs exportations
16 % par an la rupture ne résoudrait pas
à leurs graves problèmes économiques
un million et demi de chômeurs des
grèves continuent et paralysante une
inflation galopante 20% pas cependant
madame thatcher qui a des difficultés
intérieures va fêter son premier
anniversaire comme premier ministre dans
quelques jours pour l'opinion publique
elle garde cette image immaculée de
forte femme qui sait se faire respecter
et défend fermement les intérêts de la
grande bretagne
je suis très déçu et j'espère qu'ils
réussiront à se mettre d'accord au mois
de juin
que pensez vous de la position de madame
thatcher
je crois qu'elle a très bien fait je
suis très européen et je souhaite un
gouvernement européen
mais je suis content une europe dirigée
par les paysans français
je suis anglaise d'abord anglaise
absolument oui oui c'est une jolie femme
elle est très occupée
que voulez-vous que je vous dise de plus
je ne suis qu'un simple travailleur
madame thatcher est extra dommage qu'il
n'y ait pas plus de femmes comme elle
sur le fond qu'il faut y venir les
raison du désaccord entre la grande
bretagne et ses partenaires sont simples
c'est vrai que les anglais verse la plus
forte contribution financière au budget
européen pour une raison bien précise
ce sont eux qui commercent le moins avec
l'europe
un mécanisme que nous explique jean
claude renoult la grande bretagne c'est
vrai est aujourd'hui le pays qui paye le
plus pour le rang 9 milliards de francs
pourquoi parce que londres
s'approvisionne largement hors de la
communauté
les anglais à qui une taxe douanière qui
alimente le budget européen
chaque fois qu'ils achètent des moutons
en nouvelle zélande des machines en
australie ou du thé en inde
c'est à dire dans les pays de l'ancien
commonwealth où va cet argent pour 70%
ils financent l'agriculture européenne
laquelle n'intéresse guère les anglais
plutôt tournés vers leur ancien en pic
voilà pourquoi londres voudrait réduire
sa contribution
d'où le marchandage inavoué de
luxembourg si madame thatcher acceptent
une augmentation des brises agricole de
5% ses partenaires accepteront que
l'ondrp est beaucoup moins les 8 ont
même admis de ramener la contribution
britannique 2,9 à 3,1 milliards madame
thatcher
refusé résultats 1 l'europe n'a toujours
pas de budget 80 et on ignore ce que les
anglais voudront bien payé 2 les 8
millions d'agriculteurs européens ne
savent pas à quel prix ils vendront leur
lait leur viande ou leurs céréales
oui et madame thatcher toujours elle l'a
répété aujourd'hui elle avait accepté le
compromis sur la réduction du montant de
la participation financière anglaise
mais c'est sur la durée que la
négociation a achoppé les 8 proposait un
an ayant demandé 5 et sur ce point
monsieur giscard d'estaing était formel
cette exigence n'est pas compatible avec
les règles actuelles de l'europe des
neuf pas question non plus que les chefs
d'état européens se penche de nouveau
sur ce problème lors du prochain sommet
de venise au mois de juin pas question
de la contribution budgétaire reviendra
devant les instances compétentes de la
communauté c'est à dire le conseil des
ministres des finances ou les affaires
étrangères nous n'allons pas offrir un
troisième spectacle à venise comparable
à celui qui a été offert à du blast et
alexandre faut-il envisager une
qualification du désert non je vous ai
dit qu'il y avait un accord de 8 pays
sur neuf en ce qui concerne ni la
fixation des prix agricoles et ceci est
un progrès considérable puisqu'il est
encore quelques jours il y avait un
désaccord entre l'ensemble des pays
européens sur le niveau de ses prix et
fidèlement huit pays se sont ralliés au
niveau de 5% aboutissants pour les prix
français compte tenu de la suppression
des montants compensatoires monétaire à
des augmentations se situant entre 8 et
12% et avec une moyenne légèrement
supérieure à 10 courses donc lui paye
sur neuf sont d'accord et comme ils ont
le même intérêt que nous à ce que
le problème soit réglé c'est une
décision qui sera prise nous souhaitions
simplement qu'elle intervienne le plus
rapidement possible et dans l'intervalle
nous tirons en ce qui le concerne notre
nos dispositions nationales les
conséquences de cette attitude
oui ce soir toutes les organisations
agricoles syndicales françaises
réclament cette augmentation reste à
savoir si l'angleterre ne veut pas payer
qui va payer cette augmentation des prix
agricoles
la france n'était pas la seule
d'ailleurs à faire front aux exigences
de madame thatcher ses autres
partenaires étaient d'accord avec elle
notamment l'allemagne fédérale le
chancelier schmidt a fait plusieurs
contre-proposition qui elle non plus
n'ont pas abouti bonne michel meyer
désapprobation allemande est d'autant
plus grande ici aujourd'hui que l'on
croyait jusqu'à hier soir en début de
soirée que sur la base des propositions
de compromis à la fois du chancelier
allemand et du président français il
était tout à fait possible de débloquer
la situation
mais dit-on également l'entêtement
britannique a tout cassé et pour des
questions de gros sous le rock est
désunie et continue d'être en crise
alors que la situation mondiale ne
permet absolument pas une telle
situation une situation dont on rejette
l'entière responsabilité sur la grande
bretagne alors on se dit dans le même
temps s'il est bien utile d'arrimer plus
longtemps l'île britannique à la
remorque de l'europe continentale pour
la ixième fois on se dit aussi que de
gaulle avait bien raison en disant que
la grande bretagne n'était pas mûre pour
son mariage avec précisément s'être
reproduit en temps mais alors pour
terminer avec ce problème européen en
direct avec nous de londres un député
conservateur du parti de madame thatcher
monsieur roch garde d'une question toute
simple monsieur regret redonne
connaissez vous un moyen de faire dire
oui madame thatcher à un moyen de faire
dire oui cher franchement je peux pas
que ça c'est le problème
la vérité c'est que on n'est pas très
loin d'un accord il me semble mais le
gouvernement britannique est en position
si je comprends bien les règles de la
communauté a bloqué un accord sur les
prix agricoles aussi longtemps que
les autres partenaires ne sont pas prêts
à la satisfaire en ce qui concerne les
contributions au budget oui en fait il
semble plutôt que d'un seul coup la
grande bretagne ne veuille plus
appliquer les règles européennes qui
sont celles de la solidarité la
communauté européenne monsieur regarde
n'est pas une caisse de compensation on
doit y faire preuve de solidarité cette
solidarité madame thatcher ne veut pas
l'appliquer
mais vous savez j'ai l'impression que
depuis le début de la communauté les
gouvernements de tous les pays ont de
tout temps ont suivi à l'est ce qui ce
qui le regarde comme les intérêts
essentiels de leur pays et je dois dire
que on trouve en grande bretagne est
assez bizarre d'entendre les
compatriotes puis général de gaulle nous
donnons délaissant en ce qui concerne la
solidarité communautaire
oui mais là en l'occurrence vous êtes
seul quand je dis vous les anglais vous
êtes seul contre les huit autres
partenaires de la communauté européenne
alors que voulez-vous finalement enfin
personnellement j'espère que nous et
insistant surtout sur le blocage des
prix des denrées agricoles en surprises
parce que si on augmente actuellement
les prix du lait par exemple au delà
prix du sucre alors on trouvera une
augmentation encore plus énorme
tu es des 2 de la production de la
surproduction de ces dangereux en europe
à un niveau de prix que les
consommateurs ne peuvent pas supporter
alors je trouve que ça c'est idiot
cela dit monsieur garden je suis
peut-être entêté mais je repose la même
question
si vous ne voulez pas participer s'ils
ne voulaient pas de ce compromis avec
les européens
que voulez-vous que les anglais veulent
t'ils que madame thatcher vaut-elle je
crois qu'elle va certainement arriver à
un accord si c'est possible mais je dois
dire que nous avons semble plus
tellement possible maintenant mais je
m'excuse
nous avons parfaitement le droit comme
tous les autres partenaires si je
comprends bien les règles a insisté sur
notre droit de veto sur en ce qui
concerne les prix des denrées agricoles
et je crois je trouve ces d'essentiel
que le gouvernement
gouvernement le ferait si on regarde un
certains commencent à penser en france
notamment qu'au moment où la solidarité
européenne devrait jouer à plein et
faire preuve de son indépendance
vous jouez un petit peu le jeu américain
qui ne voient pas toujours d'un très bon
oeil l'indépendance européenne
je crois franchement que ça c'est un
cetain mes appréhensions si je peux le
dire parce que l'essentiel du débat
c'est de savoir si on pourrait arriver à
un accord sur les prix agricoles si je
comprend bien qu'ils ne résultera pas
dans une augmentation et est intolérable
des la surproduction et en montant et en
même temps que nous pouvons trouver un
moyen de nous accorder en ce qui
concerne les contributions au budget
communautaire parce que jusqu'à
maintenant il faut dire que seuls le
fardeau des de nos contributions nous
semble un peu excessive étant donné les
niveaux de vie en grande-bretagne et
dans les autres pays de la marché commun
merci monsieur roch garden on comprend
mieux on vous étendant en vous entendant
du moins pourquoi la négociation est si
difficile entre l'angleterre et les
autres partenaires de la communauté
européenne pour terminer avec cette
affaire européenne le groupe communiste
français à l'assemblée nationale a
demandé au gouvernement un débat sur ce
thème de l'europe
les syndicats défileront t-il ensemble
le jour du 1er mai initiative dont
débattent depuis ce matin la cgt la cfdt
et la fédération d'éducation nationale
la cgt qui propose en outre une grève
nationale le 13 mai proche
jacques merlino et au siège de la
fédération de l'éducation nationale où
auront lieu les discussions
oui daniel eh bien nous ne savons pas
encore si le 1er mai aura lieu un défilé
unitaire en effet les trois délégations
de la cgt de la cfdt et de la fen n'ont
pas encore terminé leurs négociations
vous savez que se sont rencontrés ce
matin qu'ils ont discuté longuement et
que depuis 18 heures il continue ses
négociations à l'ordre du jour il y as
et vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
donc un défilé du 1er mai dans l'unité
et ensuite peut-être un ordre de grève
générale pour
13 mai ce sont donc des négociations
importantes ce qui explique peut-être
leur longueur
mais à l'heure qu'il est nul ici ne peut
dire si l'on va vers une réconciliation
entre la cgt et la cfdt ou si au
contraire ce soir marquera une nouvelle
étape dans la division des syndicats
les noms d'enseignants ce que l'on
appelle les agents de l'éducation ils
sont près de 200 milles environ étaient
appelés à cesser le travail aujourd'hui
on les considère généralement comme les
plus mal lotis des personnels de
l'éducation ils sont chargés de
l'accueil de l'entretien de la
restauration pour mieux connaître leurs
problèmes
lauren que zain a dressé le portrait
d'une femme agent de service dans un
lycée parisien
4h30 5.4 j'arrive ici à 6h15 on reçoit
la marchandise en premier lieu ensuite
je préfère les desserts après avoir
préparé les desserts on coupe le pain
pour l' annexe parce que les nex à
fournir pour 10 heures pile où se met à
table vers 11h 11h15 et un 11h45 je
monte les entrées je mets sur les tables
je serre les professeurs je dessers les
tables je lave
je nettoie jusqu'à quelle heure jusque
15 heures tout est complètement minutes
est tout ouïe
vous travaillez depuis qu'elle a 14 ans
quel âge avez-vous que les voltiges et
il ya 31 ans je suis marié j'ai un
enfant de 13 ans ya combien de personnes
qui déjeunent ici il y avait une
soixantaine de professeurs et puis on a
question réfectoire des élèves mis les
lèvres plus donc la nec ce qui est de
250 à 300 personnes
combien d'heures travaillées vous parce
que je crois que l'on est les seuls dans
la fonction publique à faire 44 eur on
va nous dire que nous avons les grandes
vacances
chose qui n'est pas exact puisque nous
travaillons 20 jours au camp de vacances
combien gagnez-vous par mu pour moi qui
ai eu neuf ans d'ancienneté je fais 2900
francs mais pour quelqu'un qui débute
dans la forme dans l'éducation nationale
2500 francs nous n'avons pas de prime ni
de 13e
quelle est la situation familiale des
femmes qui travaillent ici il ya
beaucoup de fameux divorcée et mère
célibataire aussi bien sûr il n'ya pas
le père pour soutenir n'y a qu'une paye
et il faut quand même payer son loyer
faut payer tout on en est comme les
autres
qu'est-ce qui est le plus dur à
supporter un autre emploi alors le plus
dur à supporter le bruit d'être toujours
debout mais surtout la suppression de
postes qui fait que les agents se
retrouve avec trois quatre classes en
supplément dans certains établissements
et quand on leur envoie la superficie
que l'on a à faire tous les jours on
s'imagine faire deux trois classes en
plus vous savez c'est très très fatigant
quels sont vos rapports avec les
professeurs avec les élèves avec les
élèves pas trop mauvais bien que
quelques-uns ne comprennent pas du tout
le travail que l'on fait mine de plomb
attention à rien on est là vraiment pour
les servir on ne peut pas dire que
vraiment dans l'intérêt subo coût 2,5
pour cent de croissance pour l'économie
française en 1981 chiffre cité
aujourd'hui par monsieur raymond barre
qui parlait devant les chefs
d'entreprise monsieur raymond barre
également déclaré qu'il n'était pas
question pour lui de revenir sur la
liberté des prix
pas question non plus de céder à
l'argument démagogique qui consisterait
à rogner sur les dépenses
fonctionnement de l'administration et
l'état enfin monsieur raymond barre
s'est déclarée choquée par le peu
d'enthousiasmé des députés udf notamment
à voter le projet sur la participation
qui vient d'être votée au parlement avec
simplement cinq voix de majorité
les 22 partis communistes européens
réunis à paris ont achevé leurs travaux
aujourd'hui en lançant un appel à tous
les peuples des nations européennes pour
la paix et le désarmement il souhaite
qu'une initiative soit prise très
prochainement dans ce sens par toutes
les forces démocratiques communistes
mais aussi socialistes
sociaux-démocrates et chrétiens le
commentaire de noël comme la première
constatation c'est que tous les
objectifs fixés par les 22 partis
communistes réunis à paris correspond
aux objectifs souhaités par l'union
soviétique
qu'il s'agisse de la sphère des fusées
américaines en europe ou qu'il s'agisse
des négociations soltes en tout cas pas
plus aujourd'hui qu'hier
il n'était question de l'afghanistan la
deuxième constatation c'est que l'appel
lancé à toutes les forces démocratiques
les socialistes et les sociaux
démocrates les chrétiens et les croyants
des autres religions correspond très
exactement aux voeux exprimés dès hier
par monsieur pons de barrès au nom de la
délégation soviétique
c'est donc au tour des tests l'union
soviétique la recherche de l'ouverture
politique la plus large possible
alors cette ouverture sans doute que les
soviétiques ont-ils l'arrière français
de donner des satisfactions à ces partis
communistes européens notamment les
italiens les espagnols ils sont les
héros communiste qui n'avait pas voulu
cette conférence c'est peut-être en tout
cas une façon de relancer l'unité des
partis communistes européens alors que
l'organisation même de cette conférence
avait montré la division cette ouverture
cet appel aux hommes de bonne volonté
n'est pas sans rappeler toutes
proportions gardées sur le plan
international ce qu'avait été il y a
quelques années il appel lancé par les
communistes français autour du thème de
l'union du peuple de france
en tout cas cette ouverture aujourd'hui
est en contradiction avec la situation
de la gauche française
iran un incident a eu lieu aujourd'hui
entre les avions de chasse américains
est un avion de transport militaire
iranien qui passait au large du porte
avions américain nimitz au koweït le
ministre des affaires étrangères iranien
monsieur go daddy a été victime d'un
attentat manqué plusieurs coups de feu
ont été tirés contre sa voiture il n'a
pas été blessé
premiers sondages en france pour le
compte de paris match sur ce que les
français pensent de l'intervention
américaine en iran 52% pensent que le
président carter a eu raison de vouloir
délivrer les otages 60% pensent que si
les otages étaient français il serait
également pour une intervention
militaire
enfin 64% estiment que le président
carter ne doit pas démissionner après
cet échec et puis toujours à propos de
l'iran il une dépêche qui vient
d'arriver instant et qui indique que le
président carter vient de convoquer tous
les leaders du congrès le parlement
américain général cette convention cette
convocation d'un lieu qu'avant une
grande décision internationale c'est ce
qu'ont indiqué à washington
information générale s'est finalement
confirmée c'est la même arme qui a servi
aux tueries de carqueiranne et du
magasin mammouth de béziers le rapport d
expertise est formel tôt marc ecko
l'assassin présumé a donc désormais
toutes les chances d'être officiellement
inculpé cela très rapidement
il ya en france 70 milles divorces par
an avec à peu près 60% de consentement
mutuel et 40% de conflit il ya également
plus de 70000 enfant confié à
l'assistance publique à la suite de ces
différences le divorce est donc
aujourd'hui un phénomène courant dans
notre société et ce sont bien évidemment
les enfants qui en général trinquent
quand les parents se déchirent les
enfants du divorce est depuis hier le
thème d'une semaine dans quêtes
proposées par monique karr 1 dans notre
magazine c'est la vie
18h30 chaque soir lorsqu'un homme et une
femme divorce leurs enfants les juges et
leur jugement
vous allez le voir et sans complaisance
car elle avait tu je fais mienne en 1 tu
comprendras toi-même aussi à se plaindre
de moi à se plaindre de moi écrit un
petit peu plus vite mais applique toi
rhin qui a terminé n'a bien alors tu
relis la récitation turrel et à dicter
et je vais voir bertrand janvier les
enfants ce ne sont pas des élèves comme
les autres dans la mesure donc j'ai dû
prendre en ce moment quelques
précautions sur le plan de leur sécurité
parce que j'ai la sensibilité de leur
éducation et je veux l'assumer mais au
niveau des résultats au niveau des
méthodes l'éducation se fait sous le
contrôle d'une école avec des séjours à
irrégulière à l'école je participe
d'ailleurs moi même j'ai au moins deux
demi journées avec les professeurs à
l'école et avec les enfants en même
temps dis-moi clair il ya eu des
problèmes il ya quelques temps
oui je peux me raconter d'accord maman
il a regardé trop longtemps et puis papa
élite est triste c'est ce que voulait
nous voir en plus envie nous on prie on
s'approchait la voiture comme ma maman
m'avait dit ça veut dire quoi ta maman
m'avait dit que sorte où il fallait très
bien se débattre info fallait pas
il fallait pas cessé leur faire un vrai
papa
et puis alors qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous de ces disputes en se
mettant papa et à maman pour vous avoir
poussé patres pas vraiment facilement et
sydney de divorce et nous valent entre
papa et maman je me dis allez dehors je
peux pas tirer c ur aussi parce que non
on se balade d'un côté après d'autres
c'est dur quand même tu vas tu conduis
faire comme ça je vous en ai trouvé une
méthode pour faire ça je le souhaiterais
c'est une chose qui pourrait à mon avis
parfaitement se faire dans la mesure où
méthodes d'éducation serait semblable
or ma femme est partie au milieu d'une
crise mystique au écologique et lorsque
un enfant a mal aux dents je l'envoie
chez le dentiste jeu avec lui chez le
dentiste
quand ma femme a de son côté avec ses
amis et de soigner des maux de dents
elle met un clou de girofle avec de
l'argile
enfin je le sais parce que mes enfants
me l'ont dit j'imagine que c'est vrai
alors on ne peut pas assez soin sa
méthode soit la mienne pas être les deux
d'où le drame de ceux de mon divorce à
moi ce n'est pas un divorce ou les
méthodes d'éducation sont semblables
tout tout est opposé et tout ce que je
fais moi tout ce que je dis moi quand
les enfants sont là-bas et la maman
essaie de détruire tout ce qui est
inutile mais je pense que nous concevons
d'un côté on se fait de l'autre on est
comme des valises qui se servent de
chair à voir ce char dans la main
je pense à marc des valises qui vous
donne parfois envie un peu de pleurer
demain les pays-bas change de rennes et
oui la fille succède à la mer si je puis
dire
l événement sera retransmis par antenne
2 à partir de 13h50 commenté devinez par
qui par notre spécialiste léon zitrone
juliana et béatrix deux femmes aux
caractères très différents
la reine juliana abdique après 32 ans de
règne
elle réserver son départ pour deux
raisons d'abord il y a trois ans son
mari le prince bernhard plus compromis
dans une affaire financière celle des
abus lockheed
il reconnaît avoir été imprudent lehner
l'un des partenaires mais jules gamins
en abdiquant trop tôt aurait semblé
obéir à une espèce de contraintes
morales ensuite et comme souvent chez
les chefs des grandes entreprises
julian a estimé que son successeur
n'était pas encore tout à fait apte à
mener la barque mais cette fois ci ça y
est il y a trois mois fatiguée elle a
annoncé à la télévision qu'elle
passerait la main
ce 30 avril jour de 71 ans au palais
royal d'amsterdam à sa fille aînée
beatrix qui accède au trône à 42 points
qui était fort peu impatiente de rig
selon ce n'est pas la même chose jules
ghana est archi populaire au point que
le premier ministre monsieur allard
vient de ses grilles et je regrette déjà
mme notre bonne règle sa gentillesse son
dévouement à ces sujets a été première
bien au contraire mais afrique c'est
assez froide selon certains distinctes
c'est le revers de la médaille elle a
une volonté inébranlable et une
hostilité de tous les instants elle ne
se laisse pas adhérent public juste ce
qu'il faut mais pas plus spécialiste de
l'économie elle est tout à la fois très
européenne et disent certains une femme
de gauche des idées avancées les
souvenirs heureux est souvent évoquée de
ses voyages enchaîné en urss
à telle enseigne que la vieille garde
hernandez a peur d'une reine honte
l'expression est exagéré
d'ailleurs donné une grande place au
social cela suffit-il pour ouvrir
rapidement à béatrix le coeur de ce
sujet ce n'est pas tout avec à ses côtés
le prince claus ex diplomate allemand
lors de leur mariage en mars 66 observé
un but en plus antique pétards fumigènes
de protestation on accusait klaus
d'avoir appartenu aux jeunesses
hitlériennes
mais il réussit à se justifier les
néerlandais cyr comme s'il oubliait et
klaus passionné de nature et
d'environnement a été bien accepté mais
le voici qui montent d'un cran qui
devient mari de la souveraine un ce
qu'on sort difficile métier s'astreindre
à ne jouer aucun rôle politique s'est
passé perpétuellement devant les pouces
qui règne c'est dur mais klaus européen
très convaincu est un homme intelligent
a eu jusqu'ici sur son épouse une
influence conseil être excellent il peut
l'aider réussir selon un sondage du
journal néerlandais de sévir 60% des
néerlandais
le croit quant à julian a re devenue
princesse elle se consacrera à l'art
d'être grand mère est là de ses quatre
filles 13 petits enfants demain en
direct après heure 50 52
vous verrez notre réalisation de béatrix
en l'église hleb la nieuwe kerk qui
était en réflexion depuis 20 ans exprès
pour cette occasion là et le soir vous
suivrez la promenade du couple royal sur
les canaux d'amsterdam il dit avant de
conclure avec la météo je saute du coq à
l'âne la négociation engagée aujourd'hui
entre la cfdt la cgt la fédération
d'éducation nationale pour parvenir à un
accord sur un défilé commun au 1er mai
n'a pas abouti en ce moment même
vous les voyez sur cet écran les
principaux dirigeants syndicaux de la
cgt monsieur séguy de la fen monsieur
henri henri de la cfdt monsieur mer
qu'on ne voit pas sur cette image sont
en train de déclarer de montrer au
public leur constat de désaccord
voilà donc la météo pour terminer demain
du nord au jura le temps sera très
nuageux et frais une zone nuageuse et
orageuses accompagnées dont délocaliser
le matin sur les pyrénées s'étendra en
cours de journée sur la moitié sud du
pays
ailleurs le temps sera brumeux et
nuageux avec des éclaircies
les vents de secteur sud-est seront
assez forts sur la méditerranée voilà ce
journal est terminée ne me reste plus
qu'à vous souhaiter une excellente
soirée sur antenne 2 avec notre
ce soir les dossiers de l'écran dernier
journal hervé claude main antennes 2010
invité principal
mireille qui a invité l à ses côtés
monsieur bertrand de jaune bonne soirée
pour soi